la fête de la musique rendez vous
incontournable pour marquer le début de
l'été ce sera demain le 21 juin un
chiffre pour débuter cette séquence 32
c'est la 32e édition de ce rendez vous
initié en 1982 donc par le ministère de
la culture invités autour de cette table
jean pierre fiala bonsoir la gender de
la batterie à guyancourt et jean pierre
duvergne bonsoir je suis maire adjoint à
montigny le bretonneux délégué à la vie
des quartiers on va parler des
programmations dans vos communes mais
tout d'abord la fête de la musique pour
vous cela symbolise quoi un souvenir de
la fête de la musique peut être alors un
premier souvenir pour ma part en tout
cas c'était la toute première fête de la
musique est tel que l'avait initié de la
banque avec une expérience je me
promenais avec un instrument de musique
avec mama basse en l'occurrence et j'ai
eu l'occasion de pouvoir jouer comme
cela avec des musiciens qui venait de
l'univers totalement différent du mien
ça m'a marqué c'est un boeuf comme on
dit ça c'est vraiment
rencontré dix jours exactement et donc
là c'est vraiment un très beau souvenir
une belle expérience et ça m'a donné
d'aller rapide expérimenté aussi
d'autres styles de musique plus tard
sans faire de vern en savoie concerne
moi je crois que c'est moi je suis pas
musicien je suis amateur mais je ne joue
pas
je dirais que c'est l'expression de la
liberté la liberté de pouvoir s'exprimer
que chacun puisse exprimer en dehors de
structure figée ou plus ou moins lourdes
etc chacun peut s'exprimer par la
musique on va vous donner quelques idées
de programmation avec un aperçu de ce
qui va se passer à montigny et à
guyancourt juste après ce micro-trottoir
quel sera votre programme pour la fête
de la musique le micro-trottoir
la fête de la musique comme je suis
bassiste je vais participer à la fête de
la musique de voisins
retenu à chelsea de faire un tour
histoire de voir je vais amener mes
enfants écouter de la musique sera sur
versailles soit sur pareil
rien rien rien je vais aller avec une
amie
spécial rien je travaille le lendemain
sortie avec ma femme et puis voir un
copain qui joue la musique pas mon choix
sera dépendre du temps où la sortie
referee de bodrum passé je la mérite je
passerai une soirée entre amis après le
bac ce sera la fin des épreuves donc on
va fêter ça sur versailles je pense rien
du tout je vais rester chez moi en
famille avec les enfants je pense qu'on
n'ira probablement sur versailles son
compte enfin voir ce qui se fait dans le
coin donc je garde ça l'amusé pour le
moment je sache peu de travail si tout
est une ambiance n'est pas toujours à
faire la fête et pour autant certains
mais quelquefois un petit peu de penser
à autre chose
la plupart des communes y participe
d'ailleurs à cette fête de la musique a
fait vraiment l'unanimité
on va regarder à montigny tout d'abord
ce que vous avez prévu vous avez décidé
de mettre en place depuis 2011 ce que
vous appelez un festival itinérant c'est
à dire que l'on retrouve dans toute la
ville des scènes qui sont montés un peu
partout cinq scènes en tout cinq
ambiances oui c'est pas forcément cinq
ans bien sonné cinq scènes effectivement
répartis sur la ville donc une en face
de chaque maison de quartier ou à
proximité de chacune des trois maisons
de quartier plus une autre place des
causses sur dori nord plus un autre tir
à la principale probablement à côté la
médiathèque du canal c'est pas chaque
site n'est pas dédié on a un ami que
c'est un petit peu les styles
dans chacun des sites on arrête parti
voilà donc trois durera ce sont des
groupes amateurs alors ce sont des
groupes amateurs absolument donc il ya
un petit peu de tout comme musique il ya
d'abord de la musique classique donc à
peu près trois heures au total de deux
créneaux réservés pour la musique
classique sur les sur l'ensemble des
sites et puis on a également beaucoup de
musique
modern music musique amplifiée en fait
donc du pop rock du jazz etc et il ya
quarante groupes à peu près qui vont se
produire donc sous la responsabilité du
conservatoire des arts pour de musique
pour ce qui est de la musique classique
est sous la responsabilité du secteur
musique amplifiée pour le pour la
musique amplifiée ça c'est un gros
investissement pour la commune
alors c'est d'abord un investissement en
temps ça c'est sûr c'est un
investissement en temps parce qu'il faut
le préparer parce qu'il faut l'organiser
on a voulu en fait sur le fait de la
musique à la fois préserver le le côté
spontané mais en même temps en même
temps assurer un certain niveau de
qualité et assurer la logistique et les
moyens pour que les musiciens soient
dans de bonnes conditions et les
spectateurs soient de bonnes conditions
donc on y passe énormément de temps il
ya toute l'équipe du schéma qui
travaille dessus voilà en ce qui
concerne briller en course et aussi pour
la batterie pour le site puisque tout se
déroulera autour de la batterie bien sûr
guyancourt c'est aussi un investissement
important oui tout à fait effectivement
on mise beaucoup sur la fête de la
musique on s est un temps fort et on
essaie de mettre en valeur du mieux que
les possibles donc effectivement ça
nécessite un minimum de moyens et donc
on développe les moyens nécessaires je
rappelle quand même que pour notre part
nous sommes sur le site de la batterie
et que de ce fait en étant installé là
pour la troisième année consécutive sur
sur ce site ça nous permet de bénéficier
des matériels déjà existants à la
batterie que l'on complète ensuite pour
pouvoir parvenir à faire les sept scènes
que nous développons cette année bien
sûr il ya une inconnue c'est la météo
mais on espère que tout se passera bien
même si c'est compliqué depuis plusieurs
semaines plusieurs mois on en revient
cette programmation sur montigny vous
avez veillé justement avoir de nombreux
genres qu'ils soient représentés et que
tout le monde puisse participer à cette
fête de la musique quelle que soit la
génération oui tout à fait halloween
c'est pas de mettre les jeunes dans la
rue qui font du bruit pour embêter les
plus âgés c'est pas ça la fête de la
musique y est on est bien d'accord
le problème c'est que ça beaucoup de
succès la fête de la musique donc voilà
on regarde quand même on apprend on pour
n'a pas pu passer tout le monde tous les
groupes candidats il y en a une
quarantaine qui passe au total sur
montigny mais il y en a bien une dizaine
qui s'entraînait en liste d'attenté qui
aimerait bien passer on va voir on va
voir toute l'année prochaine en dhr je
sais pas pourquoi pas une 6ème 7ème
scène sur ce soir là comme l'année
dernière on avait fait six scènes mai
une scène qui n'avait pas fait très bien
fonctionné parce que l'était pas
probablement au bon endroit et donc là
on a préféré se concentrer sur cinq
scènes mais vraiment voir des
programmations
importe qui on va écouter l'un de ces
groupes justement qui va se produire à
montigny le bretonneux c'est le groupe
électrique sceau d'un groupe de reprises
pop rock ils seront à 19h sur la scène
de la médiathèque à montigny
une reprise des red hot chili peppers a
fait partie de vos goûts musicaux ah oui
moi j'ai des goûts très éclectiques
personnellement donc le temps vous irez
voir électrique soda absolument moi je
serais surtout les chips à ce sont des
groupes uniquement de la commune de
montigny le bretonneux quasiment oui
vivier d'artistes alors on a un vrai
vivier d'artistes et purna le fameux
secteur musique amplifiée qui est un
service de la commune mais qui est
dirigée par marc hisako et qui
accompagne on en parlera t il peu après
mais qui accompagnent les groupes dont
qui les accompagne à la fois sur la
technique à la fois sur le comment dire
le la scénographie sur
les qualités acoustiques et c'est donc
vraiment on a vraiment un bel outil qui
permet de multiplier les groupes et les
groupes qui se produisent de plus en
plus jeunes il ya des artistes très très
jeune on va écouter justement un autre
de ces artistes avant de se pencher sur
la programmation de la batterie à
guyancourt c'est kurt à 100 jeunes
rappeurs lui sera 19h sur la scène de la
maison de quartier toujours inventive
qui dit qu'ils voulaient
surtout
par ce mot
à
m
1 0
vous avez souvent
ce soir
voilà pour cette artiste qui se produira
à montigné on traverse presque la rue en
les deux communes sont voisines ont par
contre lui encourt lui en cours ce qui
est bien c'est que la fête de la musique
ce sera le 22 le samedi sera juste après
la programmation de montigny donc c'est
complémentaire pourquoi le choix du 22
pour éviter la concurrence mais c'est
devenu une tradition et effectivement il
y a beaucoup beaucoup de très gros
plateau qui sont développés le jour du
21 traditionnellement qui peu partout y
compris sur un sur paris et voilà on a
préféré effectivement toujours gardé le
rendez-vous du week-end qui tourne
autour du fait de la musique mais en
tout cas l'année prochaine nous serons
dans les temps puisque ça tombera samedi
donc là forcément ça tombait bien joué
combien de groupe chez vous cette année
c'est une grosse programmation aussi il
ya plusieurs scènes oui donc sept
plateaux développer la aussi
deux maîtres mots de la batterie c'est
toujours l'éclectisme et on s'y tient
effectivement aussi dans le cadre de la
fête de la musique nous avons nous
accueillons 32group cette année
dont 18 sont issus des studios de
répétition de la batterie on essaie de
faire de faire tourner un petit peu les
différents groupes ce ne sont pas
toujours les mêmes que l'on retrouve
évidemment chaque année et puis les
autres c'est viennent de l'agglomération
dire non à montigny-le-bretonneux vous
vous appuyez sur ce schéma ce service ce
secteur des musiques amplifiées sur la
batterie à guyancourt vous avez aussi
vos propres équipements donc se sont
demandé d'aider des artistes que vous
accompagner tout au long de l'année pas
uniquement ponctuellement pour la fête
de la musique
oui tout à fait nous avons déjà deux
animateurs qui s'occupe des trois
studios de répétition de la batterie
lesquels sont les ouvert tous les jours
de midi à minuit c'est quand même un
créneau important ça me permet aussi
d'accueillir beaucoup de beaucoup de
musiciens tout au long de l'année
il ya toujours une demande très forte on
l'a malheureusement pas toujours la
possibilité de répondre à tous et puis
ma part parmi les groupes que nous
accueillons en studio on repère de temps
en temps certains c'est le cas du groupe
alors stop ce oui je prononce bien ce
thème seront ils se produisent à 22h30
si je me souviens de la programmation et
enfin de 2h30 dans un salle de concert
c'est un groupe que vous avez accompagné
quel style de musique un petit peu ceux
du pop rock
c'est un groupe que nous avons choisi
d'accompagner nous sommes une sélection
chaque année de quelques groupes que
nous nous accompagnons ainsi avec tout
un travail non seulement autour du son
mais aussi de la mise en scène de façon
à les aider à développer un petit peu
leur spectacle ce sera l'un des groupes
à découvrir et il y aura aussi une
prestation plutôt atypique la musique
qui rencontre la peinture sigfried
demandons ségolène perron ce sera entre
l'école municipale et la batterie voici
de quoi il s'agit
non
l'artiste le peintre qui invente sa
toile au fur et à mesure que se joue la
partition de batterie c'est une manière
intéressante aussi de fêter la musique
on a évoqué le travail que vous faisiez
on va revenir aussi un petit peu son
travail du duo cemac vous avez mis en
place avec une vraie politique
d'accompagnement aussi pour développer
ses talents les produire leur permettre
de sortir aussi des disques un
d'ailleurs alors là oui ça fait jusque
là ça va jusqu'à leur permettre de
sortir un album en fait il il arrive
avec
sortent du cycle avec un master qui leur
permet derrière de de faire presser
leurs disques et de les commercialiser
on suit pas mal de gros qu'on doit
suivre une quinzaine de groupes dont il
ya un petit peu de tout
il ya du jazz et du pop rock encore une
fois
il ya surtout y en a un groupe ii
de groove et de sol qui est le groupe
que l'on suit le plus en fait en ce
moment parce qu'il est plus avancée à
tous ces groupes sont suivis par le cema
à différents niveaux ils sont
accompagnés ils sont guidés marc jacot
en réalité plus qu'un agent municipal
est un artiste donc ça j'ai l'occasion a
effectivement donné ici et de parler des
sentiments que ça aide beaucoup donc on
a deux studios de répétition pour sa
plus un studio d'enregistrement il ya
trois faire si vous êtes sur saint
quentin en yvelines si vous voulez vous
produire dans un instant nous allons
parler économie sur ce plateau alors je
vous donnais forcément quelques chiffres
pour donner le ton l'organisation de la
fête de la musique selon le ministère de
la culture c'est plus de 18000 concert
parents vivent environ 5 millions
musiciens ou chanteurs amateurs
rassemblant près de 10 millions de
spectateurs à travers la france c'est un
vrai rendez vous populaire est justement
sans faire l'oiseau de mauvais augure
mais vous faites attention un petit peu
aussi à tout ce qui est sécurité c'est
un dispositif particulier qui est mis en
place ça fait partie de l'organisation
oui ça fait partie de toutes façons de
l'organisation courante parce que
lorsque l'on s'occupe d'un lieu de
spectacle
quel qu'il soit on est tenu de respecter
les respecter certaines normes donc nous
mettons en oeuvre les différentes normes
de sécurité usuelles pour accueillir les
différents concerts dans de sécurité on
imagine aussi sur montigny le bretonneux
juste pour terminer cette séquence nous
avons parlé de saint quentin en yvelines
un petit extrait de ce qui va se passer
du côté de versailles puisqu'il y aura
de nombreuses scènes également dès 18
heures le 21 on écoute un extrait d'un
morceau de rts fc de l'électro ils se
produiront place de l'europe à
versailles à 21h
voilà pour voilà pour l'extrait de ce
groupe r tsf qui sera à versailles et si
vous souhaitez vous déplacer aller
jusqu'à paris a sachez qu'un ticket
spécial fête de la musique à 3 euros
permettra de voyager en façon illimitée
en rer métro et bus dans toute
l'ile-de-france de 17h le vendredi 21
juin à 7 heures le samedi 22 juin et
puis pour ceux qui ont des smartphones
il ya aussi l app store le googleplex
vous pourrez trouver une application
avec toute la programmation des fêtes de
la musique à côté de chez vous pourrez
partager vos photos vos impressions pour
fêter la musique merci à vous deux est
revenu sur ce plateau parler du travail
mené à montigny et à guyancourt